de façon formelle et solennel je salue
nos panélistes attia michel épaules
bonsoir à vous il faut parler de
vaccination pour commencer puisque c'est
reparti aujourd'hui au québec
le coup d'envoi un peu plus officielle
cette campagne massive de vaccination va
commencer par une donne est toute
récente
au cours des quadistes 15 dernières
minutes qui nous provient de monsieur
dubé lui-même qui a mis à jour le
chiffre en ce qui concerne les
rendez-vous 100000 rendez vous depuis ce
matin et qui ont été pris dans le cadre
de cette campagne de vaccination comme
on le voit sur un tableau qui concerne
les personnes âgées de 85 ans et plus on
sent un certain soulagement dans la
foulée de cette de cette campagne qui
s'initient et qui si tout va comme prévu
devrait nous permettre de gagner cette
guerre contre les variants vaccins
contre variant écoutant là dessus
monsieur dubé et arruda et on se reparle
non seulement failli se confirme et
qu'on recevrait 400 mille doses à mars
mais on va en avoir 300 milles de
moderne c'est à dire qu'en fait dans les
quatre prochaines semaines on va
recevoir 500 mille doses la fin mars
ça pour moi c'est une excellente
nouvelle star je vous dirais d'une
période de sécheresse de la kz1 je
l'espère et on va pouvoir maintenant
repartir la machine de telle sorte que
ces groupes qui ont l'air un après
l'autre avec énormément de distance vont
être quasiment dans la ville
bonne nouvelle sur le plan sanitaire et
sur le plan politique mais chance et oui
sur le plan politique parce que ce qui
est dangereux dans une campagne comme
celle là qui touche autant on dit que le
diable est dans les détails il suffit
qu'ils aient un problème informatique
pour que les gens disent oh ça marche
pas la campagne est bon ça semble pas
être comme ça au premier jour de la de
la prise de rendez-vous alors ça c'est
une bonne nouvelle souvenirs aux états
unis obama qui a pris des mois à se
remettre d'un problème informatique le
premier jour les sites ont été ouverts
c'est toujours ça c'est politique a
toujours peur de ça maintenant il faudra
voir comment les centres vont
fonctionner mais tout semble indiquer en
tout cas que tout est dit pour l'instant
pour l'instant et elle tient évidemment
tout le monde observe de près ce qui se
fait dans chaque province comme en
avance cette campagne de vaccination
ouais je serai pas tout va bien je pense
que peut-être les officines et que moi
avait pensé que ça irait moins bien
alors on pense que ça va assez bien mais
quand même question de commencer à
vacciner les gens qui sont à la maison
les gens quand leur ai dit de pas savoir
de leur domicile depuis un an les gens
qu'ils ont passé des heures au téléphone
et ils doivent prendre les rendez vous
des gens qui ont essayé de prendre
rendez vous piquer y avait plus de
disponibilité mais c'est vrai que le
diable est dans les détails puis comparé
à l'ontario comme exemple ça va beaucoup
mieux au québec mais je pense que la
grosse question c'est vraiment pourquoi
est ce que semblent toutes les provinces
même dray ne sommes pas avoir pris les
mois à l'été dernier à l'automne pour se
préparer pour une campagne qu'on savait
allait être énorme
puis toujours dans des questions de
santé et les gens veulent avoir
confiance dans leur gouvernement
et puis comme celle signalée si ça va
pas bien et il ya même juste des pubs
musculation les gens sans qu'un manque
de confiance dans le système iq s'impose
à bowman je pense quand même le test au
québec aujourd'hui il a été réussie vous
l'avez dit tantôt c'était le jour 1 de
la campagne de vaccination massive c'est
aujourd'hui que ça commençait qu'il ya
plein de façons par lesquelles ça aurait
pu planter et croyez moi le cabinet du
ministre dubé
il était nerveux parce qu'il pense à
tous ces scénarios locales 8h du matin
sont réunis alors que commencer la prise
de rendez vous
puis les informations qu'ils rentraient
au compte gouttes qui avait tel ou tel
du problème par exemple mois après les
cartes postales à la capitale nationale
mais ça avait été été corrigé je pense
que pour le jour 1 ça me semble avoir
plutôt bien commencé d'autant plus qu'on
sait à quel point qu'habituellement les
nouvelles technologies tout ce qui est
d'aussi informatique en santé on demande
toujours proche de la catastrophe
je pense que monsieur dubé c'est un gars
qui est un gestionnaire qui est aussi
quelqu'un qui est très intéressé par les
nouvelles technologies pilon et
s'efforce aujourd'hui autant il ya eu
des erreurs
du point de vue du québec avec le
système de santé mais aujourd'hui ça
serait peut être pas mal pire que ce que
ça a été mais il est intéressé par les
nouvelles technologies et donc ont
ouvert la porte à cette histoire de
passeport vaccinale sébastien mauvais
disait qu'un peu plus tard conférence de
presse il a admis qu'il était allé un
peu trop vite dans toute cette histoire
avec un sujet quand même qui peut
susciter pas mal de questions notamment
et tickets coûtant laitue monsieur dubé
en a par mois si tout à fait naturel de
penser qu'on aura un vaccin à sport
thaksin hadji d'ald à court terme c'est
ce qu'on a demandé en même temps comme
le docteur arruda de le deal c'est de
dire à quel moment vous avez le
passeport est ce que c'est après tant de
semaines de vaccination et c'est heureux
de ce qu'on est en train de regarder
mais on a des gens qui travaillent là
dessus michel jarre deux ans de l'adieu
beaucoup de pays envisagent ça et c'est
vrai sauf que c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
chercheurs de médecins qui disent
écoutez leur peut-être que la
vaccination contre la colombie dix ans
veut devenir une affaire annuel comme la
vaccination contre la grippe est là à
voir un passement vaccinale annuel
renouveler quand tu as valet te faire
donner le vaccin pour la deuxième dose
de la deuxième année ça risque de
devenir
qu'un fou lui assez considérable si
c'était une affaire qui on donne une
fois et pour toujours
c'est une chose si ça devient un accès à
lui elle vaudra ces pratiques de
demander son âge
oui et on voit que c'est un set en place
ce système notamment israël israël qui
le champion mondial la vaccination à ce
moment mais mais sa cause et là bas
certaines un confort certain il voyait
une injustice les vaccinés et les peaux
vacciner et deux classes de citoyens
puisque ça permet d'accéder à certains
lieux publics tout ça tient mais en fait
c'est pas une experte dans qu'est ce que
ces parfums en très basse à soulever des
questions mais oui la vie privée mais je
pense que les plus grands les plus
grandes que sens c'est celle qu'on on au
quai avec qui on n'a pas de réponse à
l'instant alors cité vacciner ça dure
combien de temps pour tous les vaccins
sont préparés et il y en a on sait que
face du moderna sont beaucoup mieux 90 4
peut-être si bon mais elle la question
de passeport dax ne s'est pas du nouveau
pour aller au brésil où se démontrer
comme les vacciner contre la fièvre
jaune
si c'est fait je pense que les pays où
la plupart de leurs populations
vont-elles thaksin et vont vouloir que
les gens qui viennent dans leurs
frontières et que cette personne soit
vacciné parce que c'est un risque reste
à des gens qui ne le sont pas alors si
je pense que c'est certain qu'on va voir
ça un jour mais on n'est pas rendu là sa
maman on voit que l'on avec vous là
dessus paul mais il ya déjà des
exigences d'être vacciné pour certaines
maladies avant de broyage rit donc pas
entièrement neuf
ça va assurément être une demande des
gens qui ont déjà été vaccinées cela dit
moi ce qui m'a surpris dans la phrase de
monsieur dubé s'est pas qu'ils en
parlent mais c'est qu'il utilise
l'expression court terme en tant qu ils
disent qu'il y réfléchisse parce que il
ya quand même
implanté un système de passeport digital
ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain
et j'ai aussi l'impression qu'il ya des
gens qui vont peut-être qu'on pourrait
être déçu parce que même si on a un
passeport vaccinale ben c'est pas parce
que vous êtes vacciné que les mesures de
distanciation sociale et de masquer mon
forcément tomber sur la santé publique a
le dernier mot là dessus mais il va en
dépression vraiment des gens qui sont
vaccinées le petit burman le réclamer
oui et des acteurs économiques aussi
qu'ils vont le réclamer j'ai été utilisé
par les festivals exactement c'est un
commerçant il faut une économie repartir
diront certains à travers tout cela je
ne sais pas s'il s'agit d'une tempête
dans un verre d'eau ou non quelques
années puis phénomène ou non me reparler
de ce tweet denis coderre qui est en
lien avec la vaccination
ça fait réagir aujourd'hui il y en a eu
deux de ses gazouillis ça c'est le
premier celui que si on veut alimenter
les débats je tiens à saluer le ministre
christian dubé son équipe notamment
sarah maude membres de l'équipe de
monsieur dubé du ministre dubé
il y avait un problème informatique pour
prendre rendez vous pour la vaccination
de mes parents et ils ont réglé la
situation en moins de deux bravo et
merci christian voilà pour le tweet
bon certains avaient peut-être en tête
cette affaire qui liait à l'époque celui
qui était à l'époque maire de montréal
et le spvm
on s'en souviendra donc ça a généré des
réactions tout ça et vous avez vu la
réaction le tweet de monsieur coderre
qui a tenté de refermer de remettre le
couvert sur la batterie la marmite
mais je vous entends des dessus d'abord
michel est ce qu'on doit faire tout un
plat non jusqu'à preuve du contraire
khadr ne sais pas monsieur dubé dit qu
il le signaler un problème informatique
qui était dans le système est qu'il ait
pas d'avoir un poste mois puis bien
franchement denis coderre qui se prépare
à revenir un petit extra secret de
polichinelle jamais assez bête pour
émettre sur twitter je pense pas qu'on
puisse penser qu'un policier qui a
l'expérience est ce qu'il aurait pu
éviter tout ce qui s'est écrit là-dessus
en envoyant remerciements privé par
exemple
peut-être
une de gestion de l'image puis je pense
que la raison pour laquelle on en parle
c'est comme vous l'avez dit c'est
monsieur coderre déjà fait ce genre
d'erreurs éthiques
mais dans ce que six mois ce conte ce
qu'on m'explique c'est que il ya plein
de gens qui ont signalé au ministère la
santé au cabinet de monsieur dubé des
problèmes informatiques et ils étaient
très contents parce que la seule façon
de découvrir ces problèmes le sait qu'on
les porte à leur attention par des gens
qui sont en train de tester le système
pour qu'il puisse les corriger
donc dans ce cas-ci ce pas monsieur
coderre qui a demandé une faveur du
sport une fonderie gérance mais ça
montre à quel point que des gens qui se
souviennent de ces ingérences passé et
peut-être au plan du pouce de la
stratégie du candidat à la mairie
attendu je sais pas s'il aurait dû ne
pas le mentionner sur tout mais bon je
pense que je me scandalise ray une autre
fois je pense que ça va être rapidement
oublier toute cette affaire ce qu'on a
davantage en tête ce qui ont davantage
en tête de bien des gens aussi est ce
qu'il y aura ou non une élection au
cours des prochains mois au printemps
tiens tiens un sondage crop la presse
allons-y avec ses résultats aujourd'hui
qui encore une fois alimenté toutes
sortes de de conjectures on voit ici
total défavorable à 57% la question êtes
vous favorable un déclenchement des
élections fédérales sondage mené je
rappelle au québec est ce que ça c'est
matière à faire réfléchir justin trudeau
selon vous à tient plus qu il
réfléchissait déjà il semblerait qu i et
ii le cas dans le bureau est terminée
c'est dans le parti libéral et les gens
qui veulent y aller
budget le scénario est envisagée à
l'automne
et puis les gens qui veulent attendre
peut-être à l'automne prochain ou même
assez de faire le mandat complet la
plupart des gens ne voient pas que le
premier ministre me décider de faire le
manteau au complet mais pour l'instant
jazz meeting le chef du npd dit qu'il va
soutenir le gouvernement jusqu'à temps
que la crise finie ça pourrait être au
moins une année de deux ans peut-être
moi ce que j'ai trouvé très intéressant
dans ce match et que tu as une 43 % des
gens qui veulent aller en élections il
sait déjà qui veut créer pour le n
10 ou le parti conservateur c'est que
les sondages crop et 10
en fait ça les aiderait pas du tout ils
sont 13% à peu près dans le fond des
âges
je pense que les gens ont pas vraiment
la tête à ça puis ça se voit dans le vin
pour cent des gens qui ont aucune
préférence
ouais on voit ici justement vous puisque
vous évoquez si ces résultats sondage
quant aux intentions là des gens des
personnes sondées 20 % pour le bloc qui
était quand même pas mal plus haut 10
lors des derniers en fait lors du
dernier
il y en a certains qui ont je veux pas
faire le procès des sondages mais
certains ont dit aujourd'hui faisons
attention ces chiffres une chaîne
faisons toujours attention aux chiffres
de ce sondage on l'a vu du nombre de
juridictions ou d'un nombre d'élections
cela dit qu'un j'ai rarement vu les
otages où les gens disent je veux aller
en élection puis quand ça arrive
d'habitude c'est que le move est déjà
dans tellement ras-le-bol du
gouvernement c'est un très mauvais signe
pour sa possible réélection dans une
petite salle fred mais bon on est en
pleine pas daigné regarder ce qui se
passe à terre neuve on est obligé
d'annuler l'élection n'auront peut-être
même pas 50% participation dans cette
élection là c'est pas ce peut-être pas
le meilleur moment pour pour ça et
d'autant que si monsieur trudeau il ya
une autre fenêtre si au mois de
septembre
presque tous les canadiens qui ont voulu
être vaccinés ont été vaccinés comme il
l'a produit là il y aura une très bonne
fenêtre pour faire les élections
oui ce pas l avoir pas mal mûri que tout
ça mais le sondage de toute façon me
semble hypothétique est prématurée parce
que même chez les libéraux qui
voudraient aller en campagne électorale
ce printemps ils sont les premiers à
reconnaître que pour déclencher une
élection il faudrait que la campagne de
vaccination a très bien et ça on n'est
pas incapable
on n'est pas encore capable de tirer
cette conclusion il faudra attendre au
moins je dirais à la mi-avril et la
population aussi il ya personne qui
bouffe qui aujourd'hui le vrai une
campagne électorale
alors que leurs parents ou son sont pas
encore vaccinés donc pas ce qui va
m'intéresser c'est parce que dont la fin
avril
la campagne de vaccination scénario où
elle vaut bien est ce qu'elle est les
gens potence de réclamer une élection
mais ne seront pas trop choquer d'aller
voter parce que l'autre chose que
regarder libéraux ces belles les
conservateurs ils sont en haut et en ce
moment ça va pas particulièrement bien
pour les conservateurs donc je pense que
ça va ça démange certaines personnes
autour de monsieur trudeau qui évite les
vaccins par un monsieur o'toole lui sa
cote de popularité est pas très élevé
oui traverse des moments difficiles et
c'est ça qui peut être la clef au final
le positionnement des adversaires sur un
plan strictement stratégie chrétiens
ouais on puisse dire quand même ce
serait plutôt comme mais même peut-être
mois du joueur beaucoup plus tard au
printemps que plutôt qui est un retour
cette semaine et il ya des voiliers
notre annonce une publicité en anglais
cette fois ci qui posait la question
encore une fois qui est un autour les
chiffres le démontrent les gens ne
s'affole et qui le parti conservateur 8
même et démangé par des différends qu'il
y ait un stage peu où le parti se situe
puis il
il se prépare à une convention le mois
prochain les choses
morale de l'histoire ça sent pas les
élections pour l'instant merci à vous
trois et bonne soirée
merci